so welcome everyone to the
asian-american Cultural Center and the
asian-american lectricity
Studies lecture series it's really
wonderful to have so many of you here on
a Thursday afternoon I know there's a
lot going on so so we're all very
grateful for your presence today so
first of all I want to thank the Center
for Trent Race indigeneity and
transnational migration for supporting
this wonderful lecture series and I'm
just really thrilled to be bringing back
two of our alumni from the Yale American
Studies Program professors Simeon man
and Liz Elizabeth's on so I'm gonna give
quick introductions to the two of them
and then I'm gonna turn it over to hear
about their wonderful work so professor
Mann is an assistant professor of
history at the University of California
at San Diego
he's an affiliate faculty member of the
department of ethnic studies and the
program in critical gender studies he
specializes in Asian American history
and transnational u.s. history with a
focus on the politics of race and Empire
he received his PhD in American Studies
at Yale in 2012 and graduated from the
University of Washington where he
received his BA and before joining the
faculty at UC San Diego
he was an Andrew W Mellon postdoctoral
fellow at Northwestern from 2012 to 2014
and also a Provost postdoctoral scholar
in the humanities at the University of
Southern California and that was from
2014 to 2015 so we're gonna be hearing
about his first book soldiering through
Empire raced in the making of the
decolonizing Pacific which just came out
from the University of California Press
last year 2018 it's a cultural history
of the US military in Asia and Pacific
after World War two and the book
explains how the United States mobilized
citizens from nations and territories
throughout the region for the US war in
Vietnam and particularly the work really
reconsiders this question of soldiering
as labor as military labor civilian
labor forms of labor that work that's
critical to the expansion of the
American Empire post-war and professor
Elizabeth's on will be
following Samia Mann and she's an
associate professor recently tenured at
Northwestern University she she
completed her American Studies PhD a
year before professor Mann in 2011 so
she has courtesy appointment oh sorry
she's an associate professor Theater at
Northwestern University she holds
courtesy appointments in the department
of performance studies Asian American
Studies and the program in American
Studies
she's an interdisciplinary scholar whose
research focuses on the interplay
between histories of gender-based
violence and contemporary performance in
the United States and South Korea her
book which we'll be hearing from
embodied reckonings comfort women
performance and trans-pacific redress is
from the University of Michigan press
also 2018 and examines the political and
cultural aspects of contemporary
performances in South Korea Japan and
the United States that have grappled
with the history of Japanese military
sexual slavery her scholarly articles
have appeared in Asian theatre journal
theatre survey theatre and many others
and she's also a public scholar she
writes off ads which have appeared in
such publications as the launched Los
Angeles Review of Books and the hill
both scholars have garnered awards for
their amazing groundbreaking scholarship
and we're delighted to have them back on
campus today so please join me in
welcoming them and the first to speak is
professor Mann
[Applause]
so thank you so much Mary and thank you
everyone for being here it's really
really wonderful to be back in the space
this is where the project got started um
being in conversation with so many
people and my cohort in our seminars and
I think it's really interesting that
even though we each have our own very
individual projects I think we all we're
grappling with some broad similar
questions right questions that were
percolating in American Studies at the
time about the limits of liberalism and
its promise of freedom through inclusion
right and ways of reckoning with
histories of violence and it's long
persistent aftermaths so soldiering
through Empire which I'm going to talk
about today really grew out of these
conversations it is an attempt to
wrestle with what I see as one of the
central paradoxes of post-1945 u.s.
Imperial culture that is how did the
United States legitimate itself as a
champion of racial equality and
democracy and yet at the same time
expanded state powers to wage war
throughout the decolonizing world how do
we reconcile the seeming contradiction
between these dueling imperatives of
liberal inclusion and racialized state
violence so I approached this question
by turning to the military and exploring
the ways that Asian soldiers were
mobilized for the u.s. for u.s. military
projects in Asia and the Pacific
especially during the Vietnam War in one
sense the book is an attempt to tell a
history of the International Vietnam war
beyond an area studies framework of Cold
War history and to think instead about
the legacies of colonialism in Asia and
the Pacific and how they continue to
manifest through the militarized labor
of their citizens and I look at these
specific sites the Philippines South
Korea and Hawaii in these countries and
territories after World War Two we see a
similar pattern of colonial subjects
being liberated from colonialism so it's
part in u.s. war this process of
ushering freedom in violence was at the
heart of u.s. imperialism after 1945 and
I call this process the making of the
decolonizing Pacific the decolonizing
Pacific is not so much a fixed geography
but rather names a historical
conjuncture in which the unfinished
struggles for decolonization throughout
Asia and the Pacific became intertwined
with and co-opted by the u.s. imperative
of securing the global capitalist
economy Asia for Asians as a discourse
and a practice was the u.s. response to
the emerging third-world it was an
attempt to pacify anti colonial
resistance and to channel the freedom
dreams of the formerly colonized into
the economy of war making so viewed
through this lens of the decolonizing
Pacific the involvement of different
nations and territories in the Vietnam
War tells us a larger story than the
International Vietnam war instead it
reveals that the war was a very ground
on which the struggles were an
unfulfilled freedom from colonialism
would be waged contained and radicalized
to tell this trans-pacific history of
soldiering I turn to the military and
examined the kinds of social relations
that have facilitated among racialized
subjects of u.s. Empire in describing
the post 1945 u.s. Empire scholars have
used phrases like empire of bases
archipelago of empire as useful as these
are in helping us comprehend the
extensive global reach of the US
military for the most part they have
actually limit us limited us in fully
understanding how the military works so
in my account the military is more than
just a transparent essence but the US
Empire whose power is seemingly
self-explanatory by pointing to its size
permanence or hidden nature instead I
approach the military as a site of
contingency where state power operates
in far more intricate ways blurring the
boundaries between inclusion and
exclusion violence and benevolence
peacetime and wartime in Asian American
Studies the military also has been
feeded in somewhat one-dimensional term
as an institution that has served to
incorporate ethnic minorities into the
nation this myopic view has reproduced
liberal narratives of race and
citizenship of the transition from
racial exclusion to national inclusion
with world war ii marking the turning
points so my examination of
asian-american racial formation through
a trans-pacific lens specifically
through the history of Asians being
conscripted to work the US military
Empire there's an attempt to disrupt
this narrative so my argument is this
that asian-american citizenship has a
genealogy in u.s. Imperial violence
their inclusion into the nation was
predicated on their mobilization to
police new boundaries of exclusion
elsewhere in the decolonizing world so
that's the crux of the larger project
and what I'm going to do now is to dive
into parts of the book to give you a
sense of that archives okay so one of
the early participants of the u.s. war
in Vietnam was this group of Filipinos
mobilized under the name operation
brotherhood they were doctors and nurses
who had received their medical training
in u.s. colonial institutions and whose
skills and desires would get channeled
into the service of the post-world War
two US Empire the first contingent shown
here arrived in South Vietnam in the
fall of 1954
soon after the collapse of French
colonial rule in the Geneva Accords
divided the country specifically they
were mobilized by the CIA as an
experiment in psychological warfare
their task was to win the trust of the
Vietnamese people and to steer them
closer to the South Vietnamese
government the CIA refer to them in
racializing terms they saw them as quote
unquote free Asians who could
demonstrate to the Vietnamese quote from
one brown-skinned to another what it
meant to embody liberal democracy if the
Philippines was the show window of
American democracy as they were
popularly known at the time right in
Asia during the cold war the Filipinos
of operation Brotherhood helped convey
that idea through counterinsurgency so
here is an image of dr. Antonio Velasco
with this first contingent and this is
actually the kinds of images that the
CIA wanted to project right of Asians
helping Asians with Americans receding
in the background or at most taking a
secondary role so two Americans
operation Brotherhood was a means to an
end of winning and securing the
population the actual medical remedy
they provided the vietnamese was in many
ways inconsequential and they actually
openly admitted that in their reports
one report written by Edward Lansdale is
revealing in the sense so in the report
he noted that besides their medical work
the Filipinos also performed a kind of
social intimacy with the Vietnamese that
was crucial to the counterinsurgency
quote they made up their own songs they
held parties and off-duty hours and in
general were a real tonic to the
dispirited even the presence of pretty
Filipino girl doctors was enough to
encourage Vietnamese to learn English so
they could talk to them and quote so
there's lancedale being kind of creepy
so it still figures quite centrally in
most historical accounts of the
philippines vietnam connection right
because he was the one who was credited
with perfecting counterinsurgency
tactics and the philippines and then
exporting it to south vietnam historians
have rightly argued that we need to move
away from lancedale because he has a
tendency of over emphasizing his own
influence but at the same time i
returned to his papers and his archives
because I think his documents reveal
what I'm calling the intimacy's of
counterinsurgency right these kinds of
social relations that are otherwise
occluded if we only focus on military
state documents
so one of the nurses Josefina Pablo
recalled in an interview she said the
Vietnamese trusted us and accepted us
very well and it was this trust that
made it possible for her to teach them
about public health Josefina was 25
years old when she arrived in South
Vietnam in 1955 she was a recent
graduate of st. Luke's Hospital School
of Nursing which was established by
Americans during the colonial period
she'll Safina saw operation Brotherhood
as fulfilling her desire to quote travel
and see the world and so puts a good use
her nursing degree
she had no expectations of securing
South Vietnam from communism that
biggert far in the back of her mind
instead she simply considered her
medical deeds on behalf of the
Vietnamese her most lasting
accomplishments so this is the point
that I want to emphasize although these
Filipinos traveled to South Vietnam as
educated subjects of the US Empire just
as Americans had intended their
interactions with the Vietnamese at
times testified to a colonial intimacy
of a different kind an affection that
refused to be instrumentalized
and that at least momentarily signaled
something else beyond the
counterinsurgency imperative at the same
time that it's important to recognize
that their desires became channeled into
the work of counterinsurgency we also
need to recognize that the u.s. projects
of securing Asia for Asians sowed the
seeds of its own unraveling as well see
in a different example so I'm gonna turn
now to briefly to Hawaii because in
Hawaii we also see the entanglements of
liberalism and state violence at work
but also the challenge posed by anti-war
and anti colonial resistance like
Philippine Independence Hawaii statehood
in 1959 was hailed as a gift of freedom
demonstrating the u.s. commitment to
liberal democracy and similar to how
Filipinos were recruited to extend that
gift to the Vietnamese discourses of
Hawaii State hoods were mobilized in the
service of war in 1965 the 25th division
known as Hawaii's own deployed from
Schofield Barracks in Oahu
coochi districts in south vietnam its
mission was standard counterinsurgency
soldiers built schools and hospitals
they launched public health campaigns
and generally sought to convey their
good intentions to the people as part of
their operation the soldiers collected
donations from Hawaii citizens to give
to the Vietnamese the operation was
called helping hand and the entire
spectacle was replete with references to
Hawaii statehood the commanding general
called it an extension of our Aloha to
the people of Vietnam and like operation
Brotherhood operation helping hands
succeeded in large part by enacting
different stories about different places
folding one narrative into another if
statehood was celebrated as the liberal
inclusion of Hawaii into the US nation
then that became the narrative frame for
the counterinsurgency as the soldier
sought to incorporate the Vietnamese
into a vision of domesticity that was
predicated on the ongoing dispossession
of Native Hawaiians of their land and
sovereign see such liberal enactments of
war could not altom utley contain the
wars brutal violence and that violence
was not the result of counterinsurgency
gone awry
but the logical extension of liberal
warfare so in the book I discussed some
of these examples of the kinds of
racialized training that's a place in
Oahu
notably right so absolute full barracks
they created a mock Vietnamese village
where soldiers trained and I've
uncovered a connection between the
soldiers who trained here in the malai
massacre that took place in 1968 so my
point in making these connections is not
simply to draw a causal connection right
but to make the broader argument that
liberal inclusion produces the condition
for state violence and it's disavowal
racial liberalism was never simply a
cold war imperative that occasionally
gets forced off by war instead war was
it's for rain upon which racial
liberalism gained traction in the
post-world War two period so I'm going
to wrap up by
discussing just one more image so this
image a map of Oahu appeared in a it was
published in an underground anti-war GI
publication called liberated barracks
based in Schofield Barracks it
introduced a critical reading of Oahu's
geography mimicking a tourist map and
guiding readers to the less familiar
sights right than what is presented
usually in a tourist brochure so in the
top left corner you can't really read it
it says under scenic points of interest
stated be sure to visit all US military
occupied lands indicated by blacked-out
areas and one of these black dye
blacked-out areas was right so pointing
the readers gaze in the middle of the
island the text revealed Hawaii's little
Vietnam as the genesis of the 1968
massacre the point of the map was really
quite simple right to make transparent
the processes of militarization that had
gone hand in hand with Hawaii's
transformation into a so-called paradise
that these occurred in locks that was
suggested by these final words at the
bottom paradise in the Pacific for
genocide in Indochina this map
represents the kind of radical critiques
against the war and u.s. Empire that
were emerging in Hawaii during this
period and on the one hand would be easy
for us to interpret this activism as a
peripheral part of the mainstream US
anti-war movements but if we expand our
view and situated situate our view
beyond the US framework it becomes
apparent that the struggles in Hawaii
were actually part of the growing
insurgencies of the decolonizing Pacific
in the Philippines Okinawa Japan and
elsewhere anti military movements were
ascendant in the 1960s base workers
American GIs labor and anti-war
organizers forged critical and difficult
alliances in an effort to end the war in
Vietnam and their governments complicity
with us and
ilysm these were all subjects of the US
Empire who were radicalized by the war
and struggled for a different conception
of freedom that did not require their
participation in u.s. state violence so
I end the book with these accounts of
these trans-pacific movements in order
to show how US militarism in Asia and
the Pacific and the broader US imperial
projects of securing in Asia for Asians
had the unintended consequence of
radicalizing the unfinished struggles
for decolonization that were foreclosed
[Music]
I want to start off by thanking Mary and
the Center for the Study of race in the
Genuity and transnational migration for
this invitation it's wonderful to share
the floor with Simeon to meet so many
students working in Asian American
Studies to see many of my teachers in
the room and to celebrate erm 20th
anniversary almost 12 years ago when I
began my research on transnational
activism surrounding the history of
Japanese military sexual slavery
I asked elderly Korean survivors of
wartime sexual violence why they
attended the 27 year long weekly protest
held across from the Japanese Embassy in
Seoul or South Korea
one woman dear one of harmony the word
for grandmother in Korean explained that
it was for the future as a living
witness she believed that it was her
responsibility to tell the world about
her experiences and to fight for justice
Kira Ngoc was a teenager in 1940 when
she was deceived into becoming a sex
slave for Japanese troops in northeast
China like guru anak girls and young
women from Japan's colonies and occupied
territories endured unspeakable violence
during their captivity in what were
essentially rape camps these so-called
comfort stations could be found
throughout Japan's colonies and occupied
territories in China the Philippines
Southeast Asia and the Pacific island
for almost five decades personal and
public silence shrouded this history
until Korean survivors began coming
forward in the 1990s and galvanized the
then NASA and social movement for
redress activists have pursued political
and legal redress that has centered on
the Japanese government's acknowledgment
of Japanese military sexual slavery and
official apology and reparations
alongside the work of activists artists
have been using various cultural forms
from literature and visual art to the
performing arts to engage with the
history of Japanese military
sexual slavery to this day the Japanese
government continues to deny survivors
full reparative measures despite the
agreement in 2015
between the governments of South Korea
and Japan to try to quote resolve and
quote the issue in response to a long
history of state denials and
half-hearted apologetic innuendos a
vibrant transnational network of local
activists has organized throughout Asia
Europe and the United States in my book
I show how the official erasure of
wartime sexual crimes in which Japan and
the United States participated after the
war and Japanese state denials of
official redress inadvertently nurtured
a transnational Asian / American
movement of activism and artistic
intervention I argue that performance
plays a central role in how survivors
activists and artists have grappled with
histories of sexual violence and the
erasers of such experiences the history
of Japanese military sexual slavery a
history that centered on the violation
of women's bodies calls for representing
mobilizing and reinvesting those bodies
with meaning the regressive acts such as
protests tribunals theatres and memorial
building the book built on the work of
transnational Asian American Studies
scholars like Lisa yoneyama and Kathleen
vials in extending Lisa Lowe's framework
of the quote tireless reckoning and
quote with a marry of America's imperial
past to trans-pacific cultural practices
of memory and justice in the case of the
government history this reckoning has to
contend with what Jana knew yoneyama
calls the quote trans-pacific
arrangement of cold war justice end
quote
Japanese state denials of the complement
history tell only part of the
multinational silencing of Japanese
wartime criminality in the United States
is implicated in official post or
Erasers of sexual war crimes
the Tokyo war crimes trials inadequate
post-war settlements for Japanese war
crimes and involvement in the afterlife
of militarized sexual labor and violence
in Japan and South Korea from 1945 to
the present by focusing on live public
enactments and interactions between
performers and audiences I probe more
deeply into the embodied aspects of
remembrance and how the everyday of
activism and artistic work can become a
sight a vibrant change that confronts
the amnesia of transnational politics
the public embodiment of memory and its
relation to community formation are
important to my study the women's acts
of remembrance are central to their
public activism communities of
remembrance are also sustained and
nurtured by the involvement of non-state
actors in activism theater and Memorial
Building as Viet Unwin writes quote
given the scale of so many historical
traumas it can only be the case that for
many survivors witnesses and inheritors
the pasts can only be worked through
together in collectivity and community
in struggle and solidarity end quote
Gwyn draws attention to the necessity of
a transgenerational accounting of
historical traumas for many survivors
witnesses and inheritors communities of
remembrance may be disparate in their
identification politics and strategies
yet they are connected by the actions of
remembrance in the pursuit of justice
for the rest of my talk I'm going to
focus on the redress of potential a
memorial building by Koreans and Korean
Americans in sore and Glendale
California in recent years as more of
the elderly survivors pass away
activists are focusing on
memorialization efforts stone and bronze
memorials to confer to comfort women can
be found all over the world locations
range from Manila the Miyako islands
and Palisades Park New Jersey Glendale
California Toronto Canada Nanjing to
Sydney Seoul is home to the original
bronze girl statue the most well-known
comfort women Memorial and the majority
of bronze girl statues have been
installed in South Korean cities outside
of South Korea the largest concentration
of compliment memorials is in the United
States Glendale is home to the first
bronze girl statue outside of Korea and
I'm interested in embodied engagements
with these memorials and what these
performances can tell us about the
interrelationship between sexual
violence memory performance and
transnational politics these bronze girl
memorials are examples of what Robin
Bernstein calls scripted things she
writes quote a scripted thing like a
play script broadly structures a
performance while allowing for agency
and unleashing original live variations
that may not be individually predictable
unquote in the case of comfort women
memorials
as script of things they invite not just
individual but collective engagement in
the ethical work of remembering
histories of sexual violence
I look at memorials as scripted things
that invite what I call performances of
care or embodied acts that materialize
concern and interest by providing for
the needs of or looking after what one
is caring for in this case memorials the
materiality design and location of
memorials shape how they prompt or
invite behaviors of care as scripted
things dressed in a humble a traditional
Korean dress the realistically rendered
barefoot bronzed adolescent sits next to
an empty bronze chair the bronze girl
sits stoic Lee with clenched fists and
closed lips she stares straight ahead at
the Japanese embassy an accused in an
accusatory manner the one could also
read a sense of peace and self position
in her stillness her body language
conveys defiance in
confidence her head is held high and her
back is straight
the statues shadow is laid out in a
mosaic a flat gray granite stones behind
her that outlines the silhouette of a
seated woman the bent back and bun of
the silhouette mark her as elder elderly
the statue is located on a sidewalk
directly across from the front gates of
the Japanese Embassy and solar where the
weekly Wednesday demonstrations take
place the location of the statue allows
multiple audiences to view the statue
the Korean public the international
public and the Japanese state artist and
the South Koreans the artist who created
the statue and the South Korean public
colloquy referred to the statue as the
swan yas'm or girl statue in naming her
the girl statue supporters and for more
fights the memorial they refer to the
statue as her and perform actions of
caring for it by dressing the statue
when it is cold or leading gifts and
letters for the statue the act of
sitting by the statues side wrapping
clothes around in or leaving gifts
literalizes keeping alive the issue and
memory of these women while giving
people a chance to perform care and to
demonstrate their public support and
this is a collage of on the top the
different outfits of the bronze girl
statue and in the lower right hand
corner you'll see the statue in
different positions so these statues in
various positions are throughout South
Korea and it's fascinating to see the
ways in which the public finds creative
means to care for the bronze girl the
bronze girl statues presence has also
rescrew today Wednesday demonstrations
in the summer of 2007 when I first
participated in the protest on average
eight to ten survivors attended the
demonstrations last summer when I
attended the Wednesday demonstration
only one survivor was in attendance
she sat not too far away from the bronze
girl statue which may soon be the only
survivor presence at the protest the
bronze girls statue as an effigy as
defined by Joseph Roach quote fills by
means of sera geisha
a vacancy created by the absence of any
original end quote while also marking
the impossibility of completely filling
that absence mung or ver moreover the
memorial as script of thing invites and
reminds the public of their role in
remembering the women and continuing
their legacy the presence of the bronze
girl alongside the lone survivor
powerfully highlights that we are at a
critical juncture there is an urgent
need to transfer memory to the next
generation as part of that transmission
of memory Korean American communities
are increasingly turning to memorial
projects as powerful redress of acts on
July 30th 2013 hundreds of mostly Korean
Americans and local non Korean
politicians gathered in Central Park in
Glendale to unveil the first compromise
built on public land on the west coast
of the United States organizers of the
Korean American forum of California
worked with Glendale silk city council
members to build this memorial which was
funded by members of korean-american
communities in the Los Angeles area
different korean-american civic
organizations across the states have
taken up the cause of comfort women and
installed memorials in their communities
while these memorials offer the public
an opportunity to remember survivors and
their fight for justice they are also
examples of how the appeal of the
comfort women issue mobilizes political
energy for other causes in
korean-american communities such as
building political alliances in creating
increasing a voter base or expressing a
group identity for many Korean Americans
commemorative practices Express a
trans-pacific affinity for the comfort
women cause that is truly rooted in a
belief in social justice others see the
memorials as a way to express Korean
nationalistic claims or to assert their
identity as a US citizen the lines are
not always clearly demarcated between
these different and sometimes
problematic motivations
the dedication ceremony in Glendale was
a carefully orchestrated event that
helped frame the memorial as a non
partisan issue that cuts across national
and ethnic differences and I'm gonna
focus on one particular speaker Kathy
misako of Nikkei for civil rights and
redress discussed her group's ten-year
grassroots campaign to win redress from
the US government for the internment of
japanese-americans during World War two
expressing her organization's support
for the comfort women survivors she
voiced the importance of an apology and
reparations quote when Japan sincerely
apologize apologizes and pays its
reparations to each of the Cumberland
before it's too late
it will help these survivors heal and
show that Japan has learned from its
past end quote
said Masako quote she continues this
monument for the government has also
reminded all of us that the abuse and
trafficking of women into forced
prostitution or domestic slavery
continues today even in this country end
quote she placed the Comfort my Memorial
within the context of a larger discourse
on violence against women noting that it
happens even in this country her
comments raised an important question
about what is forgotten when the
experience of comfort women is remember
are remembered through memorials like
the one in Glendale the plaque for the
memorial invokes the never again mantra
common to memorials to mass violence
quote and this is from the plaque it is
our sincere hope that these
unconscionable violations of human
rights shall never recur end quote
however there is no mention during the
ceremony of how these violations of
human rights might be occurring in the
sex trafficking of laborers in the law
into the Los Angeles area or in the sex
interest industries near US military
bases in Asia perhaps these absences are
invoked in the empty chair situated on
US soil as lisa yoneyama writes quote
the mark absence signified by the empty
chair placed next to the statue of the
girl unsettles view
by reminding us of other injuries from
state violence that remain equally
unseen and unheard end quote survivor
Kim bok-dong speech was the most
powerful performance I witnessed that
day dressed in a humbug with a white
chocolate top and black chima skirt she
was the living embodiment of the bronze
girl her dress in the style and color of
young girls outfits during the time that
she was taken was both a reminder of her
age when she was forced to become a sex
slave and a powerful gesture a
reclamation of that lost time elegantly
clad and speaking in clear steady words
she declared quote as I've been
traveling I have been staying
I have been saying that if Japan does
not come forward and apologize then I
will go around the world and build
memorials and quote building a memorial
is both a call for redress and an act of
redress itself she continues to say
quote the memorial is a representation
for the past history so I ask you to try
to protect and maintain the peace
memorial here and quote she invoked the
language of protection in extending an
invitation for others to join her in her
fight for justice she also articulated a
broad horizon of peace that will
ultimately be for future generations the
day after the dedication ceremony I met
the OU family they were from Riverside
and had driven to Glendale to see the
bronze girl statue the son a student at
West Point had come home for a visit so
the father decided that it would be a
good idea for the family to see the
statue together and this is a quote from
the father it seemed like a good
opportunity to talk about Korean history
when I asked him how he felt after
seeing the statue he responded quote
compared to when I read about it in
newspapers seeing it in person really
moved it articles make it seem like
someone else's story but seeing the
statue in person makes it seem like my
story end quote I was struck by how the
bronze girl's statue made the come from
in history more relevant and
personal to mr. Oh perhaps it was the
lifelike design of the statue as an
analyst incur that resonated with him
mr. O son and daughter also seemed to be
moved by the experience the son spoke of
how the statue brought history to life
for him and made him feel a deeper
connection to home quote coming here and
sitting around the dinner table and my
parents telling me stories about their
past about their history and coming out
here brings it a lot closer to home you
know being able to visually see what
they're talking about end quote
their sentiments were similar to what
people say about meeting survivors in
person or listening to their public
testimonies the Glendale statue which is
a replica of the memorial in Korea is
located on an open green facing west or
a group towards a group of tall trees
the statue and the chair are elevated
five inches off the ground on a stone
block that sits in the middle of a
gravel clearing the elevated position of
the memorial discourages people from
sitting in the chair unlike the statue
in Seoul South Korea across from the
Japanese embassy this likely also
encourages people to treat the memorial
like a shrine or grave so instead of
sartorial performances of care which
seem less necessary in southern
california's warmer weather people in
glendale are more likely to leave
bouquets potted plants and flowers and
vases around the statue the come from um
Orioles and solar and Glendale are not
simply objects with static meanings as
script of things these memorials invite
behaviors that illuminate the range of
attachments and feelings people have
about survivors and their cause
through sartorial and horticultural
performances of care individuals and
communities in Korea and the United
States demonstrate how survivors have
touched people's hearts and motivated
them to engage with a difficult
historical past approaching Memorial
Building through the lens of performance
illuminates the varied desires of Korean
and Korean Americans that inform their
commemorative practices those who dress
the bronze girl care for the women who
are sex slaves
young girls and genuinely want to honor
their memory others see the memorials as
symbols of geopolitical issues they are
committed to fighting for some see a
Korea of the past that they want to
protect the memory of and others like
the japanese-american activist in
Glendale connect the memorials to a
larger fight to eradicate sex
trafficking through interactions with
memorials such as performances of care
people become part of trans-pacific
communities of remembrance
they are commemorating commemorating not
only the wartime experiences of
survivors but also their brave activism
the act of sitting by the statues side
wrapping clothes around it or leaving
gifts provide people with the chance to
participate in something larger than
themselves and to share the comfort in
history with others while honoring the
women these performances of care remind
us of the vitality of everyday acts of
redress thank you I was wondering if the
- I was noticing how the two of you were
thinking about trans-pacific as both an
imperial designation but also a sight of
confrontation for alternative
trans-pacific trade and I was wondering
if you would comment on that and maybe
think about the gendering of the
trans-pacific in the ways you're both
using them in terms of soldiering on the
way
there on the other so I'm interested in
thinking about the trans-pacific in a
very specific moment I of the post 1945
post-world War two us projects in Asia
and really looking at using the Vietnam
War as a sight to think about the
connections of all of these different
countries and territories that we
otherwise don't see the commonalities of
so it's certainly an imperial project of
trying to demonstrate right how the u.s.
even though it's trying hard to separate
and distance itself from the Japanese
Empire of the past right it's still very
much using the rhetoric of an Asia for
Asians of the East Asia co-prosperity
sphere but at the same time we do see
that this is a project that fails in
many ways in in the sense that it kind
of mobilizes these unforeseen alliances
and interactions among different racial
eyes colonial subjects right not only
about among soldiers and civilians but
base workers right so one thing that I
don't really dwell on in the book but
it's certainly a part of this making of
the decolonizing Pacific is the
Alliance's that we see between kind of
anti-war anti-military activists and sex
workers at US bases in the Philippines
in Korea in Okinawa and Japan right so
in that sense I see the gendering of the
trans-pacific is not only about creating
it like a masculinists project of that's
rooted in the labor of soldiering but
it's also about how the military is
mobilizing different gender and a very
different like in different ways
and I'm thinking about the specific both
as a political social and cultural space
thank you first of all in terms of this
trans-pacific as an imperial project I
follow the women and how in the years
leading up to and during World War two
if we track their movement throughout
the specific it's fascinating to see
decades later how the women as activists
we circulate along those paths but as a
way to create a different kind of space
a space of potentiality for reimagining
reimagining what redress looks for looks
like for the women today I didn't get a
chance to really talk about in depth
about theatre but what's fascinating
about theatre production is about the
comfort women is that many of them have
a transnational production history so
for example there is a play the first
asian-american play about the government
in the United States by chummy Kim
called comfort women was picked up by a
Korean director she had read a review in
Korean then contacted the playwright to
translate and to bring this play to
Korea and it ended up having an extended
run throughout Korea and what's
fascinating is how this play then also
traveled from Korea to Canada so for me
it's fastening to kind of think about
not only the movements of the women
across different times but also how
cultural producers are circulating
between different spaces to create a
redress of arena where people can
re-engage with with the issue
thanks for these terrific papers really
eye-opening and moving my question is
about the Imperial move into
pre-existing structures in Indochina the
French colonial structures in the case
of post-world War two the movement of
the United States military into the
structures created by the Japanese
military almost in some cases if
regiment work correctly was a seamless
transition in the way in which that part
of the history activates a relationship
of colonialism with a deeper historical
route and I just wondered if you'd
comment on so in in Japan after the end
of World War two
there were various sex industries that
were developed around military bases one
for your place in Okinawa and with
what's interesting about these these
structures that were built earlier is
that some of the women who were come for
women during World War two many of them
decided not to return back to their home
countries so some of them ended up
staying at some of these camps and then
serving US soldiers and what's
fascinating is that in my research I
noticed that this history has only come
up when people talk about this tribunal
that was held in 2000 the women's
international war crimes tribunal which
was a people's tribunal organized by
various legal scholars and women's
advocacy organizations around the world
to bring together 64 government
survivors to redress the feelings of the
Tokyo tribunal and what's fascinating is
that during that tribunal and especially
during a there's a there is the main
tribunal and then there was a public
hearing on contemporary acts of violence
against women is when they explicitly
talked about the violence the ongoing
militarized violence against women in
Okinawa and it was during those
presentations that that legal scholars
and activists were making these explicit
connections between these different
structures of violence
it's interesting to see how that history
often is submerged and not discussed in
these different arenas of either theater
or public testimony or memorial product
so it's really interesting to think
about how the u.s. is actively
disavowing its imperial projects right
and actively distancing itself from
Japanese and European imperial powers
before World War Two so one of the
things that I'm trying to do in this
book is to really show the ways in which
contrary to how like Cold War histories
are narrated that 1945 really did not
mark a drastic break from the colonial
past and the u.s. kind of post-colonial
present or post-world War two period and
one of the ways that we see the
continuation of kind of the like ongoing
legacies of Japanese imperialism is in
kind of the desires of Korean subjects
right to join the military many of the
recruits who were recruited into the
u.s. into the Korean Constabulary right
after World War two were people who had
previously been trained or had been
officers in the Japanese Imperial Army
so there's a continuation not only like
in terms of structures right structures
of colonialism but also in kind of
thinking about the desires of colonial
subjects themselves
I have a partially formed question oh
I'm sorry
somebody else about their handbags no
okay I have a partially formed question
that I think brings the work back into
the United States proper in terms of you
know because so much of the work is out
there in the Pacific and we're tracing
these different mappings that the two of
you are bringing to the field which are
amazing but I'm sort of struck by
Glendale and some you know Southern
California and I'm thinking about how
how is this how is the work that you're
doing helping us we think something like
Glendale you know is there a way in
which that we can as scholars and the
field of asian-american studies need to
think about the local in a very
different way based on these these
mappings that you're showing us so I'm
so I feel like that's what you're
partially doing for us and I wanted to
hear I think for me what's interesting
is you know as a transnational Asian /
American performance scholar
it's fascinating when I look at a place
like Glendale because what I what I
notice is that I think to understand the
phenomena of Memorial Building in
Glendale California I think we have to
maybe step back and think about a larger
temporal time span because there's a way
in which the dedication ceremony as I
mentioned was of course highly scripted
wanted to present this like nonpartisan
issue that people across the board where
were you know joining hands for and
wanting to support the women but what's
fascinating is that the organization
behind the behind the memorial was also
a number of individuals who are at the
forefront of the efforts in the states
to pass HR 121 in the US House of
Representatives which was the first
resolution passed in the United
states where the United States called
Japan to apologize and to acknowledge
what happened to the women and what's
fascinating about that particular
resolution is that it was not only a
coalition of various Asian American
activists and organizations across the
country but it was a transnational
effort that also where individuals here
in the States collaborated with
organizations in Korea to have some of
the survivors come and testify before
the US House of Representatives so I
think that it's kind of important to
kind of think about the different
histories behind the actual culminating
event of Glendale but what's fascinating
to me is that I've been kind of tracking
what's been happening in Glendale one of
the fascinating things for me is that
and I don't understand Southern
California climate but the bronze girl
statue is no longer bronze you know
she's now become Ruston and it almost
has a greenish
finish which is kind of interesting and
it's just fascinating how that space has
not only become a place where people
come by and leave flowers on particular
anniversaries but it's now become a
space for press conferences whenever
there's like a big issue like the 2015
deal between South Korea the South
Korean government and the Japanese
government but it's also the space where
people will hold rituals and funeral
like services for survivors who have
passed away in Korea so it's fascinating
how they're very localized space of this
Park that's between a senior citizens
home and the public library if we kind
of look at it through the lens of
performance we get to see ways in which
the space has this history that is
connected not only to ongoing politics
in the States to advocate for these
women but it's connected to what's
happening abroad and for me it's fast
thing to kind of think about rituals and
commemorating the women long after they
have passed away in relation to the
ongoing quest for redress for these
women so that's kind of my long
roundabout way of kind of answering your
question about the ways in which that
very localized
space it just has so be fascinated
sedimented meanings for national
politics
and then transnational politics of
memory it's really interesting you
brought up I'm Kathy myself who was one
of the speakers because she also appears
in my project as an anti-war activists
in the 1960s yeah so I guess to answer
your question I see both asian-american
Chi eyes and veterans and right anti-war
activists in Little Tokyo in like
wherever in the United States really
making sense of what was going on in
their local communities right through
the language of US imperialism and state
violence in Vietnam right so I mean
that's that's a familiar story and kind
of the civil rights black power
asian-american movements right the ways
in which state violence overseas became
a way to really frame and understand
what was going on with urban renewal
with policing right but also I see kind
of domestic space foreign space as
really like the boundaries of that being
incredibly blurred right and we
definitely see that in the case of
Hawaii where the militarized racialized
training practices in Oahu had a direct
correlation to the kinds of violence in
Vietnam right we can also talk about
Camp Pendleton in South in Southern
California and the ways that right the
again the racialized training practice
is there with the more recent Wars had a
direct relationship with the state
violence overseas so I see it's a
different way of making sense of like
what we think of as domestic spaces
right that it's always tied to Imperial
projects elsewhere
I have a question for professor
I was really struck by a leading of the
empty chair and the bronze girl memorial
as potentially an invitation to think
about solidarities and alliances are
forged between the comfort women
movement and other sort of supporters of
state violence I'm thinking about the
memorial circuit in San Francisco that
has three women sort of holding hands
for the woman which is a different sort
of way of mass hunting not going to the
public member name so I would love to
hear your thoughts on the ways of these
different forms of sculptural
commemoration invite different kinds of
yeah political possibilities
see as well as bring back into focus
yeah
so to my knowledge the San Francisco
come from immemorial the the trio is the
only come from immemorial that
materializes this image of solidarity
and what's fascinating about that that
in particular Memorial is that it's
located in Chinatown but it's in st.
Mary's Park which is a public park and
it's fascinating to see the coalition
work across ethnic boundaries to make
that particular memorial fascinating and
when I visited last year what struck me
about that particular memorial is the
ways in which it invites the pedestrian
to also move in this circular movement
right because you're walking around and
also most importantly looking up at the
women in a position of veneration but
what was fascinating about the time when
I visited is that if you looked across I
forget which direction it was but it's
across the street there's an art school
and on the wall darts go baby you saw it
was a flag the Imperial Japanese flag so
fast thing to kind of think about within
that one space how you have different
conflicting ideas around that particular
time right and what it means to remember
world world world war ii but i think
that that particular trio of memorials
is i mean for me what really struck me
about that memorial is not only is it a
trio of three different control men on a
pedestal but there is a statue of kim
hak-sun harmony so she's the first
korean woman who came forward on august
14 1991 and was fascinating is that she
is standing and she's looking she's
looking at this trio so it raises this
interesting question about time and also
about integer what the intergenerational
reckoning of this particular history and
that kind of duality between the young
girls and the older grandmother figure
is something that is repeated in the
bronze girl stature that i talked about
we're behind the bronze girl statue you
the mosaic of an elderly woman and that
I caught I cannot feel the young girl
and the grandmother figure has been used
throughout the social movement
particularly in South Korea in terms of
the rhetoric that's used at protests but
also in the actual visual visual
iconography in terms of images on
banners actually I have a question for
and I hope you know its intrinsic you
and I have a comment I was really
interested also in the memorialization
Xin the US and I was wondering if there
are locations in the US and Glendale and
New Jersey right invited a kind of a
different kind of critique among Korean
Americans about the role of the u.s. in
perpetuating the system of sexual
slavery like after World War two like if
that contradiction of having these
memorials in the u.s. ever month yeah
so the first Memorial on public land on
the East Coast was in Palisades Park New
Jersey outside of the public library and
in my interviews with various people
involved in that particular memorial
project and also my attendance at a
dedication ceremony I people did not
express this kind of criticism and
indictment of the US and it did not
surprise me that of course in the
dedication ceremony that would not be
expressed because part of the
possibility of even having the memorial
on public land meant that there was
coalition building between Korean
Americans and non-koreans
but what but what I found fascinating
about that particular memorial is the
backlash how a number of Japanese
politicians came to visit them the mayor
mayor Rotondo the
say what these people are saying it's
historically false why would this little
city get involved in this particular
issue you know we want to give you all
these gifts of cherry trees if you will
remove the Memorial and the mayor
famously said you can keep your cherry
trees we're keeping our Memorial and we
did our research so it's fascinating how
this particular memorial kind of has
taken on this life in this community
because after that pedir incident then
and it was reported and of course a
number of different Korean newspapers
that kind of unleashed this memorial
building effort across the states where
different Korea American organizations
were saying you know we're gonna build
our own memorial well but interestingly
enough this kind of critique I have not
I have not encountered as much during
these kind of public ceremonies but I
find this critique in cultural work like
theater that this theater becomes the
space where people are able to talk more
about not just us complicity and what
happened but also are able to talk about
Korean complicity and what happened um
so for me just the common and kind of a
connection is it's fascinating that the
government survivors have become
advocates for other women who are
survivors of gender-based violence so
two survivors started something called
the butterfly fund in 2013 where when
they would go and testify they would
collect funds and different
organizations would raise money so these
these women could support victims of
other gender-based violence and one
group of women they supported were
Vietnamese women who are survivors of
sexual violence committed by Korean
soldiers during the Vietnam War and
what's fascinating is that a number of
the government activists from the main
organization have been going to Vietnam
to collect public testimony and what's
fascinating is that they're using some
of the same rhetoric they used to
advocate for redress from the Japanese
government to now
advocate for redress for these
Vietnamese women from the Korean
government and just fascinating to see
you know the kind of entanglement
between these different histories of
gender-based violence but ways in which
also it's
not just in the structures of violence
it's also in the different modes of
political organizing yeah I remember
seeing that exhibit at the women's Human
Rights Museum in Seoul where the last
exhibit at the time was a special
exhibit um devoted to this issue and I
thought it was so powerful that it
expanded the issue and also critiqued
like Korean like state violence during
the war
I think this is the really if so this
was a treat to get to anybody talking to
each other so I think this is a great
place dad let's give a wonderful
[Applause]
[Music]